The design of this shoe starts in Oregon in 1981...
...and with a man called Tinker Hatfield.
He was an architect for Nike,...
...hired to draw up offices and showrooms on the company's campus.
Hatfield headed to Paris in search of inspiration.
While he was there, he visited the Pompidou Centre,...
...a radical building famous for its inside-out design,...
...which exposed the building's components...
...like escalators and heating pipes for everyone to see.
Hatfield decided to apply the same principle to his own design,...
...revealing the inner workings of his shoe...
...by making the air cushioning system visible.
The marketing team thought the air bubble would seem like a weakness,...
...but the Nike Air Max 1 was an instant hit when it launched in 1987.
Originally, pairs sold for 75 dollars. Now they go for double that.
Stylish and innovative, this is the design that stayed one step ahead,...
...simply by being turned inside out.